ces affaires un échauffement commun avec
tout le groupe suive hattrick cavs lors
l'entraîneur de l'essor présente la
séance d'entraînement inscrire leur nom
au palmarès de la coupe de martinique
c'est l'objectif de cette génération de
jouer au prix chutent après une première
partie de championnat souvent proche de
la relégation
laissons aux prix chotin au prix de gros
efforts à a quasiment assuré son
maintien parmi l'élite du football
martiniquais
maintenant les joueurs ont la tête sur
la finale on va tout mettre dans de côté
pour un bon match mardi et massa jours
sur le terrain ça se voit depuis ici
vous mardi au procès de concrétiser ses
bonnes affaires face aux golden laguiole
il faudra user de stratégies tactiques
de stratégies tactiques et de les avoir
de la chance puisque c'est qu'on nous
rencontrons l'ordre du football
martiniquais l'équipe qui marche très
très fort en ce moment là sur un match
je crois que tout est possible donc on
va essayer de mettre toutes les chances
de notre côté
essayez de les pousser dans leurs
derniers retranchements et c'est gagner
cette coupe aux pêcheurs maintenant
c'est très bien ça
extrêmement difficile mais indien
qu'impossible n'est pas très chaude
toute la commune sera derrière son club
afin de réaliser l'exploit
on va jouer notre chance à fond la
caisse
la population prix shot in bon pense
justement cette finale oui oui parce que
nous sommes jamais mal est si on a des
tic
enfin tu es tout pour descendre tout
moment où ge a dit non tous nos lives ne
supporte laissant sa session pour la
coupe remonte à aux pêcheurs pour les 16
cas ce mineur après l'assaut les
surprises au teint parviendra-t-il à
ramener le trophée de la coupe aux
prêcheurs
réponse mardi soir sur martinique la
première